[Music]
[Applause]
when it comes to first-person shooters
there's quite literally nothing more
old-school than shooting Nazis in the
face it was pretty great 22 years ago in
Wolfenstein 3d and it still hasn't lost
its charm in this year's sequel
Wolfenstein the new order
despite the ability to now look up and
down this new wolfenstien is just as 90s
as an episode of 9:02 100 the game's
hour-long prologue is packed with nods
to classic Wolfenstein gameplay like
finding a secret room behind a portrait
[Music]
getting your face bitten off by a dog
firing a giant spinning chain gun
taking a chainsaw to some guy's head
actually I think that's more of a doomed
thing look the point is Wolfenstein the
new order feels like an old-school
first-person shooter you don't
regenerate all of your health so you
need to rely on health and armor pickups
to stay alive now the Nazis kind of
actually help out here every time you
shoot one his helmet falls off so you
can pick up that helmet to restore a bit
of your own armor it's a simple and
satisfying float you shoot a Nazi you
take his stuff you get to live longer
yay really this flow extends to the
enemy dogs as well they're wearing dog
body armor so after you kill them you
take their plating and you can strap it
on to restore your own armor okay so the
protagonists of the new order is a guy
who runs around killing dogs wearing dog
armor and eating dog food okay look just
trust me on this okay we're not really
supposed to ask why just like we're not
supposed to ask where one guy keeps all
those guns and grenades I wanna say is
neck it's just unashamedly ridiculous
just like a new perk system if you
perform enough stealth takedowns you'll
unlock the ability to throw a knife the
more knives you throw the more you'll be
able to carry that makes no sense but
it's kind of cool because it feeds into
the different playstyles that this
Wolfenstein allows for on top of its
old-school shooter mechanics the new
order injects some variety and depth
into the business of while shooting
Nazis you can lean in any direction
which is super important when you don't
have regenerating health
you'll encounter nazi commanders who
will run to an alarm and call in
reinforcements unless you take them out
first and you're gonna get hit on by
some creepy nazi general but even after
a cold shower it's clear that this
Wolfenstein is prologue is hotly paste
you'll gun down Nazi planes sprint down
Nazi trenches rappel up Nazi walls and
basically just shoot a whole lot of
Nazis in the face
but there's one thing that this
wolfenstein needs to ensure that it's as
old-school as humanly possible
they showdown with Mecca Hitler Bethesda
wouldn't confirm whether the robo Fuhrer
would return in a new order saying only
that Hitler was killed in Wolfenstein 3d
and the publisher hasn't said anything
beyond that about Hitler at this stage I
don't know what's more surprising that
Wolfenstein 3d story is canon or that
Hitler might not be dead but if the
series is essentially Nazi deaf porn
Nazi stuff then killing Hitler that's
the money shot
[Music]
Wolfenstein bring it on
[Music]